[Applauso]
[Musica]
buonasera
avete mai visto dal vivo sì mi piacciono
pura passione e solo attraverso la
passione riescono a stare a un metro e
mezzo di distanza a 700 chilometri
all'ora
oggi abbiamo sentito un cose molto belle
tra la timidezza la stupidità io mi sono
veramente divertito e ho preso a casa
delle dei concetti adesso mi piacerebbe
che ognuno di voi guardasse dentro la
propria vita e vi porto volare come una
freccia
andiamo a vedere quali sono le
caratteristiche dei piloti
avete conosciuto i piloti non vi vedo
quindi dovete girare la testa più
velocemente non li avete mai visti
perché loro pensano la squadra non lo
sono team
adesso vedremo una delle caratteristiche
per stare in squadra che sarà la
capacità di vivere interiormente un
obiettivo ma di essere consci della
mission del gruppo non c'è un ego
particolare ma lo vediamo abbiamo dentro
di noi andiamo a vedere alcune
caratteristiche che possono essere utile
nella nostra vita per vedere quali sono
le cose che io sviluppo all'interno
della mia storia e adesso per loro
faccio la selezione sono partito nel
2000 facendo molto lavoro all'interno
del gruppo e poi le procedure ovviamente
vanno avanti per conto loro
non ho bisognerà hanno bisogno della
baia e quindi io faccio adesso solo
selezione perché non si può sbagliare
quindi abbiamo una procedura di cinque
giorni dove cerchiamo le persone super
selezionate che possono entrare a far
parte della pattuglia di uno dei brand
più incredibili al mondo più
riconosciuti anche dalla ferrari è
riconosciuta ma le frecce hanno una
caratteristica che non c'è una
competizione e c'è qualcosa di veramente
magico e speciale
vedete la parola equilibrio l'altro
giorno la in tangenziale a bologna siamo
tutti in coda tangenziale e quindi siamo
fermi mi giro e vedo uno di fianco a me
che stava urlando come un pazzo stava
sclerando in un modo incredibile non so
cosa stesse dicendo che stava dando i
pugni sul volante
io che sono uno psicologo circo da
aiutare gli altri
titolo giù il vetro e dico ha bisogno e
le ho detto fate anzi tuoi ho tirato su
il vetro e intanto pensavo accidenti
speriamo che non sia il mio chirurgo
speriamo che non sia il pilota che vi
porta a lanzarote piuttosto che d'altra
parte quelli che cos'è l'equilibrio
dentro di noi è la capacità di gestire
ciò che sono io il rapporto alle vinto
che devo vivere ed è una versione di
priorità cioè persone che se la prendono
per nulla in azienda vedono delle
persone sarà bianca delle riunioni sono
delle persone che abbiano per quanto
fanno degli errori persone che sarebbero
perché sbaglia la pizza al cameriere e
di come doveva i tesori che ti taglia la
strada il recupero 3 metri rischiando la
vita rischiando un incidente
voi non fate così perché siete qui siete
sani di mente faccio un persone
veramente strane in giro sotto c'è
scritto non sono scritte due cose
vedendolo dentro di noi la priorità cosa
vuol dire vuol dire dare la giusta
energia alle cose che ti accadono dare
la giusta energia la giusta tensione
alle cose che in un qualche modo ti
stanno accadendo le situazioni io vi
faccio pensare adesso è una cosa che
veramente mi porta dolore stress
piango avete pensato
non avete certo pensato fatto che
avevano fregato la birra c'è una coda in
autostrada avete pensato cosa di più
gravi la morte di un figlio non posso
neanche immaginare io sono marito e
padre morto in un genitore ma è una mia
malattia mi licenzio non posso più
pagare il mutuo e quindi ho tutta
un'attenzione interiore
avete pensato questo questo è le altre
cose sono meno prioritaria e nella mia
esperienza c'è un 45 cose visto che
lavoriamo spesso il lavoro nei motori
quindi sono quello di simulatori che
cerca di aiutare i piloti frenare e
mezzo metro più in là
quando lavori tra la vita e la morte
riesce anche a capire che ci sono delle
cose che non va la pena spiegare se tuo
figlio ti ho portato un 4 in matematica
devi farlo ragionare quindi tanta
passione e la fonte fondamentale poi
questi piloti guadagnano anche poco
perché vanno circa dei 2200 2000 e 2.200
euro al mese io che lavoro con persone
valerio 100mila euro al giorno
mi piace come stipendio mi immagino
abbastanza amy budget abbastanza però di
bacci denti non è la felicità che ti
porta il denaro ti porta la ricchezza
una ricchezza è un'altra cosa la
felicità e dentro e se non è la passione
della non esiste nulla se non c'è un
qualcosa che ti porta dentro cuore
dentro la pancia che ti fa vivere col
cervello la conoscenza con il cuore con
la passione ma soprattutto con
l'emozione guadagni tanto ma non vuole
niente persone che fanno solo soldi
quando mi dicono quanti soldi hanno
fatto io faccio sempre solo una domanda
e dentro cosa hai costruito
qual è il tuo rapporto con tuo figlio
con tuo padre è stato bellissimo vedere
i due padre e figlio quali ha ricordato
il rapporto con mio padre è il momento
in cui ci siamo veramente riabbracciati
un insegnamento per tutti e non
aspettate tanto per fare quello che
hanno fatto loro due e quindi priorità
vuol dire avere chiarezza di tutte le
cose che ci possono stressare e le altre
pazienza vanno ragionato
ecco la gestione dello stress che è la
capacità di mettere insieme alcuni
strumenti razionali che ti permettono di
capire che anche energia entrare dentro
le cose con chi energia uscirne avete
mai schierato in un'autostrada si sento
sì la prossima volta fate un analisi
della questione
cercate informazioni trovate alternative
mettere in pratica è la soluzione
finisce lì
e infatti quando vedevo questo tizio
quando ha chiuso il retro dopo avermi
mandato a quel paese
mi chiedevo ma questo va come arriva a
casa stasera picchierà i bambini minimo
e alla fine dell'anno non stupisce è la
gastrite il mal di testa
cos'è la pressione alta e chiaro che se
gestisci così la tua vita diventa un
problema
ecco l'equilibrio e la prima
caratteristiche che cerchiamo
all'interno del pilota l'altro
dell'altr'anno avete parlato degli
errori
ecco la nostra tendenza è quello di fare
zero errori ecco cercare di gestire bene
l'errore precisi maniacali nella cosa
perché se sbagli di un millimetro
ovviamente muori fare bene al primo
colpo
mai come colui occidente farebbe nel
primo colpo concentrazione operazioni di
12 ore stanno dico la testa non è che
fanno le cose che ho visto fare il
ristorante oggi c'erano ragazze che
mangiava fumava guardava il telefono
tortellini in brodo buonissimi però di
una cosa farà bene
tendenza a gestire l'errore fai un
errore processa lo ma noi non
arrabbiarti su questo zero errori vuol
dire tendenza a gestirli il pilota delle
frecce portato a fare più di quello che
è necessario fare il 101 per cento e
questo ci affascina andiamo in un bar al
di là del caffè
pensiamo che c'è una persona che quando
empatiche fa più di quello che è
necessario ci possa felicità mi capita
non vado nel bar dove caffè migliore te
lo sbattono lì ma vado nel bar dove c'è
empatia dove c'è la persona che
sorrideva persona che ti accoglie la
persona che riesce ad essere passionale
nella tua storia
ecco fare più di quello che necessaria
che l'azienda che non vuol dire fare più
ore a fare bene quello che stai facendo
mettendoci un valore aggiunto qualcosa
in più che è bellissimo che diceva prima
chiara tutti possono cambiare tutto può
essere cambiato questo è straordinario
ego 0 e dicevo prima voi ascoltate avete
conosciuto le frecce ma non avete mai
conosciuto i piloti è davvero ovvero il
lavoro nello sconosciuto
non voglio fare il furbo ma sono capace
di essere all'interno di una mission che
le donne che sono in sala e anche i papà
sicuramente lo zero lo fanno in famiglia
l'avete mai rinunciato a qualcosa perché
c'è l'ala giro da pagare o siete
abbastanza siete quelli che guadagnano
100mila euro al giorno
avete fatto qualche sacrificio questo è
lo zero l'avete fatto per i figli ad
arriva il pollo non è che vendette la
forchetta e mangiate per primi da coach
e il petto lasciate leggo 0 vuol dire
non essere protagonisti a collego va
contro il team be fa casino perché si
muove in una direzione completamente
diversa
il protagonista è spesso vive
l'orticello a nvidia negli altri della
cui regola è il tuo successo è il mio
insuccesso e per questo si svaluta
mentre invece tutti noi godiamo quando
una persona che amiamo a un successo
meraviglioso ha un qualcosa che dentro
ci fa star bene vedere una figlia o
figlio sul palcoscenico che fa il saggio
di fine anno e fa bene la sua poesia ci
fa lacrimare per chi la passione quinto
punto l'ultimo atteggiamento mentale
positivo ovvero la capacità di vedere
qualcosa che ti porta opportunità e non
tensione e tutto questo è il pilota
delle frecce tricolori che noi possiamo
vivere anche dentro la nostra vita
seguendo qualche piccola regola se vuoi
avere quello che non ha mai avuto
devi fare quello che non hai mai fatto
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]